[Music]
Ryan Wagner was in his early 20s when
like so many young men his life derailed
he became addicted to drugs he was
depressed he also watched a lot of porn
and porn gave him the idea that he might
in fact be a woman so he consulted
doctors and very quickly they put him on
estrogen and that made his problems much
worse
Brian Wagoner no longer believes what
his doctors told him he does not
identify as female he is back to how he
was born a man and he joins us tonight
to explain what he went through Brian
thank you so much for coming on tonight
um what if you could just sum up the EXP
I'm sure this is a three hour long
conversation but if you could sum up the
experience the amazing experience you
had
how would you describe it
well uh thank you for having me on
Tucker I appreciate it
um yeah like you said
um when I was a young man when I was in
college about close to a decade ago
I was extremely alienated I had a drug
problem mainly crystal meth and other
party drugs and I went down a bizarre
rabbit hole of online pornography and I
developed a sex fetish very embarrassing
to say but it's the truth that's right
and um I went to go see a therapist who
specialized in sex issues and she told
me that I was really a woman and that
she and I had the same brain and that
basically all my problems in life were
because I was actually a woman in a
man's body even though I had severe drug
problems I had mood disorders and other
you know issues I looked terrible when I
went to go see this woman I was
underweight I was paranoid out of my my
mind from using methamphetamines and
none of that mattered it was all about
having me go to a clinic to get
prescribed estrogen and medicine to
prevent my body from making testosterone
which I took for many years and I all my
problems got worse it didn't help me it
just added new problems
and I just feel like the therapist I
went to go see was an activist who just
so happened to practice therapy too
and here in California there's really
nothing to protect people from it now
it's even more uh quite frankly crazy
it's um you can just go into one of
these informed consent clinics and you
don't even need a therapist's letter
anymore and it's completely
patient-led it's the only form of
medicine that's patient-led so I just
advocate for
better safeguarding and high quality
assessments because I want to help
everyone whether you're d-trans or
transgender I want everyone to have good
health care and everyone should be
protected and as it is now
detransitioning I just feel like I'm a
collateral damage for for a movement
that I'm not even part of they
completely ignore me and they don't want
to hear these stories but
my story is real my pain is real and
yeah it's a real thing but I just thank
God every single day of my life that I
never had any plastic surgery I took
hormones and it messed me up I had my
facial hair removed but I do think that
I'll be able to bounce back from this
and the way I always describe it Tucker
is I feel like once I got sober I I
started to have actual gender dysphoria
when people were treating me like a
woman when I I didn't before
so
yeah I mean it was like leaving the
Twilight Zone you know some of the
better episodes of The Twilight Zone is
when the protagonist leaves the Twilight
Zone but everyone else is still in it
but yeah and I just I feel like I've
been harmed by this and I just wish that
you know I don't want anyone else to
experience what I experienced so I'm out
of The Twilight Zone and you know I'm a
very happy and successful man and um you
know I just hope that my experience
helps somebody
I I don't even it's one of the saddest
stories I've heard in a long time I
don't have anything to add to it other
than I hope you tell your story far and
wide I hope it's heard by a lot of
people I think you speak for many and
I'm grateful that you were willing to
tell us your story Brian thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight